a surprising Shanks moment in one Piece
Film red is sure to please fans of the
mega popular anime one Piece Film red
premiered in Japanese theaters in August
of 2022 and almost immediately reached
some major milestones at the box office
a little more than one month after its
release it earned more than 15 billion
yen placing it among some of the highest
grossing films in Japanese box office
history
while this latest movie is effectively a
non-canonical Side Story its value to
veteran one piece fans lies partially in
how film red incorporates certain
characters for the first time by
including red-haired Shanks and his
pirate crew in a non-flashback storyline
alongside long-time protagonist Luffy
and his Shipmates shank's appearance in
film red is notable in and of itself in
that Shanks is introduced as a key
character at the series outset but has
yet to factor into the story of one
piece since then outside of some
peripheral involvement as it turns out
film red not only includes a rare
shank's appearance but demonstrates the
power of His conquerors hockey for the
first time as well just after the big
climactic battle in one Piece Film red
some Marine Admirals attempt to approach
Utah and possibly apprehend Shanks as
well whose Bounty is one of the highest
of all living pirates in response Shanks
unleashes a massive outpouring of energy
that collapses every Navy Grunt and even
brings some Vice Admirals to their knees
while shanks's use of his conquerors
hockey doesn't significantly affect the
two Admirals they decide that a battle
against Shanks would be unwise given
that civilians are present and wielding
such great power in the midst of
non-combatants may result in unwanted
casualties in this scene Shanks
conquerors hockey is effectively a
warning shot meaning that the full range
of his powers remains largely unknown
nevertheless shanks's defense of utta is
the closest look at shank's strength
from throughout all of One Piece thus
far be it an anime Canon a non-canonical
Side Story or the original manga series
in the world of One Piece hockey is a
catch-all term for a few different kinds
of extra sensory abilities that can only
manifest in extreme conditions
technically the skypia arc introduces
hockey for the first time as a power the
residents of its sky island call Mantra
then just before the time skipped that
bisects the first and second halves of
One Piece retired pirate Rayleigh
instructs Luffy on how to utilize hockey
and his lesson serves as the Fan's first
proper introduction to hockey in its
various forms Rayleigh teaches Luffy
about observation hockey which allows
its user Advanced forms of perception
Armament hockey which can bolster its
users attack in defense and conquerors
hockey which is effectively an
expression of willpower that can
physically overwhelm those of weaker
disposition hypothetically anybody can
learn to wield observation and Armament
hockey but conquerors hockey is a rarity
available only to those lucky enough to
win the genetic lottery so to speak
Luffy and Shanks are both capable of
wielding conquerors hockey and Shanks
even lets out a weak version of his
conquerors hockey when he meets with
Whitebeard just prior to the Marine Fort
Arc it's only in film red however that
Shanks lets his conquerors hockey loose
giving viewers a look at the true extent
of his power for the first time teas
though it may be the inclusion of Shanks
conquerors hockey in one Piece Film red
is significant in that it demystifies
even if just barely a character shrouded
in questions ever since his introduction
at the start of one piece and continuing
through the nearly 25 years between then
and his film red debut a Reddit read
from September of 2022 for example lists
five options in a poll asking users to
vote what they would most like to know
about Shanks Each of which is a separate
question raised about his character at
some point in one piece and the most
upvoted response in that thread one user
wrote where is Shanks who is Shanks why
is Shanks when his strengths which is
Shanks meanwhile the director in charge
of dubbing one Piece Film red Anthony
bowling highlighted shank's involvement
as one of the movie's highlights in an
anime News Network interview saying fans
are going to love what they get to see
with him and This Crew though Shanks may
not be the focus of film red the fact
that he actively engages in a fight
alongside Luffy and his friends marks a
one piece first imbuing the mysterious
character with some much needed context
as one piece inches toward its final
stretch
[Music]
foreign